so do you I was watching a backstage
that was like I would wear that always
coveting of all the bright color
obviously the cinemas great color
this is gorgeous I like a pant I have
item too as you can sharing stone
without Sharon Stone Age hunter
percentage that Sharon pebble yeah see I
went to go visit the superstore with the
teachers yeah oh my gosh it was so cute
we were waiting and we cut we were in
the middle of shoot again so they're
like oh just go over to the other stage
and wait for Kelly Clarkson to come and
surprise all these music teachers the
cameras are on us we're all ready to go
we're waiting and America just turns to
me I had no idea what was going on and
she was like are we supposed to pretend
we're not losing our minds that we're
about to meet Kelly Clarkson off so well
alright I thought she played off so well
like I didn't I wouldn't have even known
she knew a song she owned oh she's
obsessed oh yeah yeah like legit and
literally you'd come in and she was like
hi maybe like oh my gosh you're cool so
well towards the end you said something
about like you guys should all come you
know visit us on the show sometime and
she I don't think you heard her she went
yeah you'll be friends that just blows
my mind I don't know have you ever just
lost it when you met someone and you
were like wait that was not a cool
moment oh yes me so many times I think
the most memorable would be this was
this is my first movie role I ever
booked it was in a film called Lars and
the real girl starring Canada's
sweetheart Ryan Gosling I was like I
know that I'm Canadian and I was still
living in Canada at the time so it was
like date it was day one at the entire
production it wasn't just my first day
because I had a smaller part it's the
first day of everything so there's kind
of a buzz around everybody is I know
ever but all them all the other smaller
part actors we all know each other we're
like oh my gosh Ryan Gosling like what's
this gonna be
and then he shows up and he had gained a
bunch of weight for the role and and had
grown this mustache you know that's the
day the notebook died right
yeah 100% and so and so but but but
there's like a hush your mom it's cuz
it's Ryan Gosling and nothing with
everything you're still like oh my god
come on and so we did we did a couple of
rehearsals and then we were being sent
back to our trailers as happens and I
was walking in front of a friend of mine
a lady named Aurora and I turned back as
she was talking to me she's like oh my
gosh even with the weight even with the
mustache she's so hot
but what she didn't know was Ryan
Gosling was right behind her and I
wanted to be a good friend but I also
was like I can't show him that I'm
showing her so my way of handling this
was just speeding up to a door and I go
to push through the door and I hit it
because it was a pull and so I smash
into this door so hard and I turn around
to see Ryan Gosling who in full costume
full getup method actor super serious
just laughing just out heard laughing at
me oh my in Barris myself luckily every
morning at 10 a.m. in front of a whole
nation is the humiliation I've made a
career embarrass myself in front of
Meryl Streep in front of the nation yeah
it was I didn't know people were filming
and I know she was gonna be there and I
yeah she's probably scared me know I
think something we have been common I
didn't really get to talk to you cuz we
had the teachers there and everybody was
but I think we're very similar in a
sense of like body positivity and I love
that about you yeah
[Applause]
we're all different sizes different
points in our life and that's okay and I
think it's especially for women in this
business it's so important to have
people that are really confident
comfortable in their skin and I'm just
have you always been that way just
curious you know I think it's an ongoing
battle I think that every woman can
probably attest to that but it was
earlier it was I don't usually do New
Year's resolutions but this year I was
like you know what I'm going to resolve
to not speak negatively about my body
to anybody to be anybody else or to
myself you know I could tell you 25
things right now that I hate about my
body but I could probably also tell you
25 that I like I was like I'm just gonna
focus on the things that I like and I'm
not gonna focus on the other things and
what's amazing is that it disarms people
so there'll be times in conversation
I'll be like well you know I have the
greatest but in the business and people
are like oh my gosh don't talk
negatively about myself anymore and so
you know I put up a bikini post I was in
Hawaii and I put up a post of myself
into the case so all your bikini part
I'm like if I like that like you're like
really really thank you but it for me it
was like I would never normally wear
something that tiny I would never
normally post that publicly but it was
important to me because I was like I
feel fabulous and it was such a just
making that small mindset shift even if
I think something negative the fact that
I'm not saying it out loud has made such
a difference and I really can't
encourage people more but you know what
I'm the same way because a lot of comedy
comes from self deprecation but I was
like you know what there's lots of
things about myself I can make fun of
that don't involve my appearance yeah so
many oh I have a lot of this
I love though and I'm curious if you
ever had a cake like this you had a butt
cake yeah so I was I so two years ago
for my birthday wait just wait for it
you didn't see the buddy's hairy back
over in about 30 seconds I years ago I
was throwing this big girl's party in
Palm Springs for my birthday and I was
like oh I've never had a bachelorette
party should I get like a fun
Bachelorette type cake you know maybe
some male anatomy and then I was like
you know what no I'm gonna celebrate my
anatomy so I had a picture taken of my
butt in a thong and I sent it to a baker
and they made a cake in the like
[Applause]
hey Jerry have you ever done are we
gonna get to eat some I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this